The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Today
we have two guest lecturers.
The one I invited is
Professor Peter Furth.
He's an expert on
transit signal priority.
His own work on reliability
before time and then how people
budget for their
travel times, he's
a really good teacher on that.
And he's also a bike expert.
He's really interested
in all bicycle stuff,
but let's not do this publicly.
Maybe you can get
him out of this class
and ask him something.
Then we also have-- he
dragged someone else
in from the Netherlands who
also knows a lot about transit
signal priorities.
So I don't really know
what to say about him,
but we'll find out.
Maybe you can introduce him.
PETER FURTH: Yeah,
I'll introduce him.
Yeah, OK.
Hi all.
Thanks.
It's great to be here.
Before I get into
transit priority,
I just want to tell you a
bit more about my background.
So, I studied here
at MIT, and my focus
was on public transportation.
Then, I became a
professor at Northeastern.
And after several
years, for one thing
there weren't enough jobs
in public transportation.
And my students needed more
training in traffic engineering
because there were
more jobs in that.
But then the other thing is
that our buses were getting
stuck in traffic all the time,
and I wanted to learn, well,
can't we figure out a way
to make the lights turn
green for a bus.
I mean if we can get a
man on the moon surely
we should be able to get the
lights to turn green for a bus.
So I got the chance to
go to the Netherlands
for a year, a sabbatical year.
And almost did a
second PhD there,
studying traffic signal
control for transit priority.
So you have to learn all
the traffic signal control,
and then you can learn, OK, now
how do you do transit priority?
Then I came back to
the United States,
and it took me
several years to try
to figure out how the Dutch
traffic signal control--
they use different language
but it's really about the same.
There are some differences
but it's mostly the same,
how to say that in American
traffic signal control.
And since then, I've
done a lot more work now
in traffic signal control
and transit priority.
So that's how I come here.
My title is, Is it
help or is it hype?
And I really mean that
because if you go to Zurich
transit signal
priority is real help.
I went there once on
an official visit,
and I told the people
I was visiting,
I came here because I've heard
it said that the trams never
have a red light.
He said, Yeah, well
that's just about true.
There are some exceptions
he said, of course,
like at the main square
there are so many trams.
They come from
different directions
so one tram has a red
light for another tram.
But otherwise, there are
only one or two intersections
in the whole city where
the trams don't just
get a green light.
I learned that in Portland, when
they designed their light rail
in the 1980s, station
to station green waves
are programmed into the
traffic signal control.
Now it doesn't mean zero delay
because what that means is when
a light rail train
is at a station,
there'll be a countdown
clock for the driver.
So there's no point in
leaving now because you're
going to have a red light.
But if you wait until the
appointed time to leave,
then you will have a green
wave to the next station.
But then we come to
applications of transit signal
priority in the US.
And you hear these great
pronouncements, oh, we're
doing transit signal priority.
But when you look into it,
there's almost no benefit.
Sometimes they're saving
the bus two seconds
per intersection or less.
Often they're not
measuring at all.
So then I have to ask, is it
really a help or is it hype?
And so what I'm going
to tell you today
is some of the standard
ways of doing transit signal
priority, how they
work, and how they
don't work very [AUDIO OUT]
have to do to really
be able to have our buses or
trams have nearly zero delay.
So before we get
into detail, why
are we doing transit priority?
This is a class on
public transportation
so it probably doesn't
need a lot of argument
but we start with a
societal objective.
Transit offers many
benefits to society
in terms of congestion, air
quality, livable communities,
and so on.
And transit is mostly
competing with car use.
And what transit can do is
break the vicious cycle.
There's a vicious cycle.
This is especially strong
in developing countries.
Whereas people get
more money, one
of the first things they want
to buy when they have more money
is a car.
And then with the car the
car roads become congested
and then that
slows down transit.
So then people don't
want to use transit
so then they get more cars
and it just keeps going.
If you can do priority
for a bus, then
that breaks that cycle
and now people will say,
I'm going to use the bus or
the train to have priority.
And then having priority for
transit makes a lot of sense
because the tradition in Boston
has been a very extreme all
or nothing priority.
We know one way to
give transit priority.
Total grade separation.
We build a subway, and they're
protected from congestion.
So we know how to do
the $2 billion priority
and we also know the other
extreme, which is nothing.
Buses you're welcome
to use our roads.
I mean when the light turns
green everybody else can go,
I guess you can too.
It doesn't make sense to
only have those two extremes.
And that's what the
city of Zurich did.
The main planners for Zurich
wanted to build a subway.
This was in the 1970s.
Big cities that didn't
have subway systems
then were building them.
But the citizens said, no,
spend a tenth of the money--
because subways are
incredibly expensive,
spend about a
tenth of that money
to give our trams
priority, and then we
don't have to walk
down in the basement.
And instead we like how
the trams are right.
It's almost like an
extension of the sidewalk.
You just step on,
ride, step off.
So it makes sense to have
some means of priority that's
in between all or nothing.
And we have two ways
of doing priority.
It's priority in space.
That means you give the buses
or the trams their own lane,
their own space.
And then there's
priority at time,
which comes at traffic signals.
Priority, it's easy to see what
it means to a transit user.
It means you get a faster
ride and a more reliable ride.
So it saves you time.
The reliability means it also
saves you in buffer time.
But it's important to know
what transit priority means
to a transit operator.
The savings in time
means they might
be able to run their route with
fewer vehicles and less labor.
And the improved
reliability means
they don't have to have
as much recovery time.
So in Portland they had a
case at Tri-Mat Line 12.
The transit priority they put in
didn't reduce the running time
that much.
But it reduced the
variability of running time
so much that they were
able to reduce the cycle
time by 11 minutes.
And if you reduce the cycle
time by 11 minutes on a route
that runs every 11
minutes or every--
then you save one
bus and one operator.
And that lowers your
cost tremendously.
So priority is important
for passengers,
it's important for the operator.
And I told you I studied traffic
signals in the Netherlands
and it was in the context
of transit priority--
how can we make
transit service better?
So here you have two
graphs, each line
represents the
trajectory of a vehicle.
On the bottom is space.
We're going from station
CL across to station S.
And on the vertical axis is
how far off schedule are we?
So if you're at the
0 line, that means
you're perfectly on schedule.
And as you go above the line,
you're earlier and earlier.
And as you go below the
line your later and later.
So this is what the
operation was, kind of
if you just let it be.
The buses will start
pretty close to on time
but they got later and later
and later, and the spread just
gets worse and worse and worse.
This is nothing new.
If you know about
transit service
you know how there's
these random shocks
could make a bus late.
And once you're late you become
later and later and later.
And once you're early you
become earlier and earlier
and earlier.
But here they put in
a system with priority
at the traffic lights.
And it's conditional priority.
If the bus is early, no priority
for you but if the bus is late,
we're going to give
very aggressive priority
so that bus can cruise right
through the intersection.
So if the average time to
get through an intersection
is let's say half a
minute, but with priority
that's going to be 10
seconds and without priority
that's going to be 50 seconds.
That's a 40 second
difference that I
can make my bus 20 seconds
later by not giving it priority.
I can make my bus 50 seconds
earlier by giving it priority.
So with that you see how
much tighter the lines are,
how much better
the reliability is
because the priority system
is able to keep those buses
right on schedule.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
people driving on the road
would have to use
that traffic light
and they know it normally
takes them 30 seconds and all
of a sudden it's 50 seconds
or is this a separate thing?
PETER FURTH: No,
this is not let's
hold the light red extra long.
This is just we won't
give priority, that's all.
So, yeah when I say we
won't give priority,
I'm not talking about holding.
So we're not deliberately
holding the light red.
It's just, if the bus arrives in
the light is green, OK bus you
get to go through.
But if you arrive
when it's red, I'm
not going to hurry up and
turn the light green for you
if you're early.
I'm only going to do
that if you're late.
And priority makes
transit more competitive
because after all if transit
has to stop to pick people up,
that slows it down, you have to
walk to get to the station that
adds more travel time.
How can we compete with car?
Well one way we can compete is
we can give transit priority
and it makes it more acceptable.
And because I got late, I
get don't get to tell you
the story about my great aunt.
So there are different
levels of priority.
One of the things you'll
often hear if you ever
hear a presentation about
priority, they'll say,
it's not preemption.
Preemption is a technical term
in traffic signal control,
and preemption is what
we'll do for a fire truck.
And that just means oh,
preempt the signal, just stop.
Every conflicting movement
goes to yellow, goes to red,
and we just stop everything so
the fire truck can go through.
And by the way the street
that the fire truck is on we
don't turn that one red, we
would make that one green.
It's not like we ask
everybody to pull over out
of the way of the fire truck.
We ask everybody just keep
driving, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go.
Give them green
wave, go, go, go,
and then the fire
engine comes along.
So that's preemption.
We do that for fire engines.
And we do that for trains
because trains can't brake.
You get a train coming along
at 40, 50 miles an hour,
trains-- that steel
wheel on steel rail,
they can't brake very quickly.
So we will preempt
a light for a train.
So priority is something
short of preemption.
For instance, with
transit priority
we will not cut off
a pedestrian phase.
There's a certain
clearance for pedestrians
to be able to cross the street.
You've seen the
countdown signals.
So for a fire engine
they'll just--
it could be 15, 14, 0.
But we won't do
that for transit.
And preemption it doesn't
think a moment about the impact
on the other traffic.
We got to save a life.
Somebody's life is at
stake, somebody's house
is burning down,
and there's a train
coming that would kill
everybody in its way.
So when it comes to saving a
life you don't worry about,
is it costing people a few
extra seconds, minutes of time?
But transit priority
we're going to give
priority to transit vehicle
every five minutes every,
three minutes.
You can't be
completely disrupting
and screwing up traffic
every three minutes.
You have to think about
how it affects others.
So there are some
standard tactics.
The main ones I'll talk
about are listed here.
Green extension and
early green, but I'll
also talked about some
more intelligent tactics
and some ways of
changing the background.
So let's look at the most
popular tactic, which
is green extension.
Green extension means the
street that the bus is on,
the light is green.
It's about to turn
yellow, but we detect,
oh, there's a bus coming and
it's only 12 seconds away.
All right, then we'll
just delay turning yellow.
We'll just extend the
green, and then the bus
will come right through.
And then the light can
turn yellow and turn red.
So that offers, as I have
there on the slide, a very
large benefit to the buses
who take advantage of this.
I mean, because the bus who
gets the green extension, that's
the bus that if they
didn't get that extension
they would arrive right
near the beginning of red.
And they'd have the longest
wait of anybody in the cycle.
They'd have to wait whole red
period until they can finally
go on.
So if the red period
is 70 seconds long,
you just save that
bus about 70 seconds.
So it's a very large benefit,
but it's a benefit only
to a few buses.
Because which buses get
to enjoy that benefit?
Only the ones arriving during
the first few seconds of red.
Let's say you're willing to give
a 15 second green extension,
then any bus arriving in the
first 15 seconds of red that
gets a benefit.
But if the cycle
is 100 seconds long
and buses arrive at random,
well that's only 15%
of the arrivals that
are in that window.
So green extension
is a large benefit
but to a small number of buses.
And we can model that
benefit this way.
On the horizontal axis
is time in the cycle.
And on the vertical
axis, I have arrivals
and so you have cumulative
vehicles arriving.
And then the red lines
going across, that's--
you're raising your hand?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
PETER FURTH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So but
now that you said,
it's a large benefit to
a small number of buses--
PETER FURTH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --per intersection
because if the whole bus run
is 10-20 signal
intersection, then over time
the probability of every single
bus enjoying that and every bus
that runs [INAUDIBLE]
PETER FURTH: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You say it's only 15% of
buses, it's actually a lot more
and it's--
PETER FURTH: So let's say 15%
of bus arrivals at a signal.
AUDIENCE: At a signal but--
PETER FURTH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --over
a lot of signals?
PETER FURTH: Yeah.
Yeah.
If I'm running a route in which
I'm going through 20 signals
and I'm going to get the benefit
of 15% of them on average,
I'll get that benefit,
well, that would
be three times 15% of 20.
Yeah.
So the red lines here
represent the time
that a person is in the queue.
So like the car arrival--
here's arrival
number one and then
this line is the
departure curve.
Cars arrive at a
relatively slow rate,
let's say one car
every five seconds.
And they pull out at a much
faster rate, say one car
every two seconds.
So each horizontal line
represents a certain vehicle.
So let's say the vehicle
number two arrives here.
And vehicle number two
doesn't depart until here.
So that horizontal line
is the waiting time
of vehicle number two.
So in this representation,
horizontal distance
is waiting time.
So for the bus with
a green extension,
instead of red starting
at times throw,
the red actually doesn't
start until here.
So a bus that would have
arrived and had been delayed,
now those buses aren't--
buses that arrive after
the extension time
still are delayed.
So the possibility
for delay, which
is represented by the red
area, there is less of it.
And you find the average
horizontal length
between these lines.
And then you do a
little bit of geometry.
And we find that the expected
delay in the first case,
this is the standard
delay for cars,
has to do with the length of
the [AUDIO OUT] car, the cycle
length, C, and the ratio
of the arrival rate
to the discharge
rate, that's v over s.
And when we put in
a green extension,
we have that same term
minus this term here.
And I give that the
name the priority push.
So that's the reduction in
delay thanks to green extension.
And that reduction
in delay has to do
with how long an extension
are you willing to give.
In some places though
they say, well, I'm
willing to extend
for 10 seconds.
In Toronto, they often
say, I'm willing to extend
for 30 seconds.
So it depends on how
long is your extension.
But it also depends a lot
on how long is your red
and how long is your cycle.
So just so you can
have some numbers of--
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
[INAUDIBLE] why is the order
[INAUDIBLE] assigned to that?
PETER FURTH: So this line here?
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
PETER FURTH: OK.
So that represents the
cumulative departing cars, OK?
So at a certain point in
time, the light turns green
and then the first car departs.
The second car doesn't depart
until about two seconds later.
The cars follow one another.
So this line has a
slope of about one car
every two seconds
as they depart.
This is as they arrive.
It's maybe one car every five,
six, seven, eight seconds, OK?
And where the two
lines meet, that
means the last car in
the queue is now gone.
And after that, as cars arrive
and depart without any joining
acuity, just go through.
So to put some numbers
on that priority push,
let's consider a sort
of typical intersection
with a cycle length
of 100 seconds,
50 seconds of red
time, and the v over s.
That v over s term is such
that the degree of saturation
is 85% which that's
pretty typical.
So this shows how the
priority push varies
with the green extension.
The longer an extension
you're willing to give
the more of a priority push.
But notice they're not
equal to each other.
For instance, when the green
extension is 15 seconds
that gives me a priority
push of about eight seconds.
So often if anybody does try to
describe the priority tactics
they're using, they'll say
something like, oh, when we
give 15 second green extension.
Well that doesn't mean it's
going to speed the buses up
by 15 seconds.
In this case, how it
affects each individual bus
varies but on average that will
reduce the delay of buses--
this is averaged over all
buses, reduce the delay
by eight seconds.
And then it has a lot to
do also with the cycling.
So let's again consider
100 second cycle,
degree saturation 85.
This time hold the
green extension period
fixed to 15 seconds.
And look at different
amounts of red time.
So if you're red
time is low, that's
like the buses on
the through road that
gets green most of the time.
We're green most of the time and
only a small part of the cycle
is for the cross street.
Well then the priority
push is pretty small,
only about five seconds.
But if the red time is long,
if it's 100 second cycle
and the light is red for you
90 out of those 100 seconds,
well then getting pushed ahead
15 seconds will save you a lot.
Now when is the light red
for 90 out of 100 seconds?
Under what kind of
traffic movement
would it be that is
red almost all the time
with a very short green?
AUDIENCE: Maybe like a city
center pedestrian plaza?
PETER FURTH: No, probably not.
Because if you only
give the cars 10 seconds
you just can't get
much traffic through.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: D street
in South Boston.
PETER FURTH: Ho, ho,
ho, ho, ho you got it.
You got it.
But that's not a typical case.
AUDIENCE: The cross streets
of a major thoroughfare?
PETER FURTH: So
the cross streets,
even they get more
like 25-30 seconds.
AUDIENCE: Like a
protected class.
PETER FURTH: A left
turn, that's it.
This is the one that
really, really could
benefit from a green extension.
So right next to Northeastern
is Ruggles Station,
and you got all these
buses making left turns.
And if they don't
make it, uh sorry,
120 second cycle,
100 seconds of red.
So that's a situation where
a green extension would be--
it's valuable in all these cases
but it's especially valuable
when there's a
really long red time.
So I'm glad you
mentioned D Street.
I'll be talking about D Street.
All right.
OK, how do we do detection?
Technically to detect the
bus, it's almost trivial.
There's so many
different ways to do it.
I'll say something about
technologies, but where
we want to detect the bus.
So we want to have a check-in
detector so the bus reports in.
Hello, I'm a bus.
Can you give me priority?
And there is a trade-off.
The sooner we know,
the better because then
we can prepare for it and
get that light to be red.
But if you tell me
two minutes in advance
there's a bus coming, bus travel
time is not deterministic.
All right?
So there might be stops in
between and random dwell time.
There might be other
traffic signals in between.
So usually we want
our check-in to be
as far away as can be but no
farther than the next stop
or the next intersection
so there's a pretty
deterministic travel time.
We also want there to
be a check-out detector.
Some systems omit the
check-out detector.
So if you omit the
check-out detector,
here's how inefficient you are.
You say, oh, there's
a bus coming.
I'll give it a 15
second extension.
The bus goes through
after three seconds,
and you still hold the
light green for the full 15.
That doesn't make any sense.
So have a check-out detector.
As soon as the
bus hits that, you
cancel the extension request,
let the light turn yellow.
The traditional
technology for extension
is we bury in the
ground a loop--
not just a dumb loop
of cable but a loop
that acts like an antenna.
So the bus is coming along,
giving along a very low energy
signal.
I'm a bus.
I'm bus number 2356 so you
can check my ID to make sure
that this is not a stolen unit.
And it could give
off some information
like, I'm turning left
so I need the left arrow.
There's another bus route coming
along that's going straight.
So that's one way of doing it.
Nowadays, we'll be doing it with
GPS and basically cell phone
technology, texting.
The bus sets up text messages
with the controller and says,
here are my coordinates,
and just keep sending
essentially the packets of cell
data like text messages.
And then we know where the bus
is, and we can take action.
So I can skip that.
So one difficulty
of giving priority
is, well, what if
there's a near side stop?
If you looked at
locating stops for buses,
you know there's a basic
choice between the near side,
the upstream side
intersection or the far side.
Well, if you're
on the near side,
remember stop dwell
time is random.
So I don't even want
to check the bus
in until it's left the stop.
Well, that means
my check-in point
is going to be awfully close.
So what?
I'm going to find out two
seconds before the bus comes
that a bus is coming?
If you only have two
seconds advance notice,
how long a green
extension can you give?
AUDIENCE: Two seconds.
PETER FURTH: Two seconds.
Think about it.
You can't give a
15 second extension
if you're only detecting the
bus two seconds early, right?
If I was going to end
the green at time--
let's just pick a
number at time 50
and I said, oh, I'm willing
to wait till time 65.
But I don't know when the
bus is there until time 63,
how would I know to
extend the green?
Yeah.
You cannot give a green
extension longer than
the advance notice
that you have.
So this is a killer.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious
about the actual mechanics
of the signal extension.
PETER FURTH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this
a signal you're
sending to just that one
traffic intersection or are you
sending a signal to some
central control that's
controlling the whole
city's traffic lights?
PETER FURTH: A single place.
Now, it can work through
the central place,
but I'm talking
about, yeah, a bus
is detected for a
particular light,
hold that particular
light green for me.
It doesn't do anything to
any other intersection.
AUDIENCE: But I meant
does it send a signal
to some central control
which then tells that light
to change?
PETER FURTH: That's an option.
So in Zurich, yes, they
do that but man you need
all kinds of cabling for that.
In Zurich the controllers on
the street are 100% slaves.
All they do is, when
the central computer
tells them to change from green
to yellow they just say, yes.
And the only other software
they have running in them
is some kind of checking to
make sure that they're not
violating something.
But that's a very unusual
setup that was done ages ago.
Nowadays we have very
reliable microcomputers
in the controllers.
So the central
computer will make
sure every intersection
is on the clock,
every intersection is supposed
to have its certain offset--
you turn green at a
certain time in the cycle.
And it will give them
the basic parameters--
30 seconds for this street,
20 seconds for this phase,
20 seconds for this
phase, and so on.
And it will say,
and you're allowed
to give a 15 second
green extension.
And then it's the
local controller
that will actually do it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] means
that the detector is right there
at the intersection?
PETER FURTH: Well it means
that the stop is just
before the intersection.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PETER FURTH: So if
I put my detector--
normally, let's say I want to
give a 15 second extension,
I locate my detector 15 seconds
upstream of the traffic light.
Well, what's 15
seconds ahead when
there is a dwell time in there?
So you know how random
dwell times are, right?
Are there going to be one,
two, five people getting off?
How many people are getting on?
Maybe somebody who needs
assistance or having
trouble with their fares.
So because of that we won't
usually call for an extension
if there is a stop in
between because we don't
know how long it's going to be.
So near side stops, not entirely
but they get some benefit.
If the bus is pulling out
two seconds of extension,
that's nice but it's
only two seconds.
So it nearly kills
the effectiveness
of green extension.
So that's a reason if you
want to do transit priority,
you review your
route and you say,
can I move the stops
to the far side.
There are a lot of other reasons
to move stops to the far side.
Transit agencies around
the country where they can
are moving stops
to the far side.
So in the NBTA recently
they did a review
of all their key routes.
And one thing they looked at
is, can we relocate stops?
But they have criteria--
where there's a stop there has
to be a level landing place.
There can't be fire hydrants
and telephone poles in the way.
There can't be driveways.
So some of the streets that
I've looked at for, could we
do transit priority, and first
thing I would say, oh no, it's
a near side stop.
We've got to move it to the
other side of the street.
But on the other
side of the street
there's a driveway
every 30 feet,
you can't put a bus stop there.
Or there's a firehouse, you
can't put a bus stop there.
So sometimes we're stuck
with near side stops.
And then green
extension just ain't
going to help us very much.
OK.
Before I go into
more tactics, let
me go through this list
of common weaknesses
in trying to do it.
So one weakness that I've
seen a lot here in the US
is what I call
cautious priority.
So all this equipment they
put in this transit priority
system.
But the traffic engineers
are so afraid it's
going to screw up
traffic that they'll say,
once we give
priority to a bus we
inhibit the whole
system for five minutes
to give the signal
a chance to recover
or we inhibit at least
for another cycle.
Or if the traffic level on
the cross street is too much,
just turn off the
signal priorities.
OK.
So the Silver Line running
on Washington Street
has a priority system.
Some of the cross streets
have so much traffic
that they have this rule--
if the cross street volume is
too much, turn it off.
Well it's turned off, OK.
So the bus never gets
priority at Melnea Cass,
it never gets
priority at Mass Ave.
Many of the cross streets
bus has the green light
for like 70 out of 90
seconds in the cycle.
So it's almost always
green so the bus almost
never needs priority.
So there is priority, but
the benefit is very time.
So in the end, what do you get?
You get almost nothing.
And then a second
weakness is not
thinking about the impact
of priority on traffic
and then unnecessarily
hurting traffic,
like not having a check-out
detector that I mentioned.
But the second
bullet there, that's
an important one I want you to
think about, is compensation.
Compensation is a key
to making priority not
hurt traffic so bad.
And by compensation
what do I mean?
What I mean is if I'm going to
give the bus street 15 seconds,
I'm taking those 15
seconds away from somebody.
Are you going to give it back?
The language that
traffic engineers use
is they use the word borrow.
They say, oh, we'll just borrow
15 seconds from phase two.
And then I ask are you
going to give it back?
And they say, well, no.
I say, well, then it's not
borrowing, that's stealing.
So if you take away 15
seconds from phase two,
and phase two now they
can't clear its queue.
So now it's going to
have a long queue.
And then the traffic
engineers will say, oh no,
now if we let them have priority
in the next cycle as well,
oh no, what a disaster.
So that's why you
get these rules,
like if we do priority, no
priority for the next cycle
or the next five minutes.
But if I hold the light green
for let's say East Street
for the bus, so I hold
the light green 15 seconds
for East Street, who's
going to get through
in addition to the bus?
A bunch of cars, right?
A bunch of cars who otherwise
would have been in the queue
for the next cycle.
So that means when we come
around to the next cycle,
East Street is not
going to need as much
green because some of their
cars already got through.
Meanwhile, other streets
whose green we took they
need more green.
So hey, why not just be
reasonable and fair about it.
Since we gave East Street some
extra green, in the next cycle
we'll give the other
streets extra green
and we'll take some
away from East Street.
That's compensation.
That's a sensible
way of doing things.
And what you'll see
is we don't do that.
We can't do that with much of
the standard way of controlling
lights that we follow
here in the US.
And that's the
inflexibility that I'll
be explaining later on.
Then another weakness is
we'll do the easy things.
Green extension is easy.
So we just do green extension.
And then, like I said, if
you have near side stops,
well you don't get any benefit.
And there are other tactics
that are harder to do,
but we only do the easy ones.
And then the last weakness
is failing to collect data.
In something like this,
it's hard to get it
right the first time.
You need to do it, collect data.
See, are my buses getting the
priority they're supposed to?
If they're not, make some fixes.
Is car traffic doing all right?
Are there places where huge
queues are building up?
And try to fix it.
So take the objective seriously.
So now I need to move
away from transit priority
and just tell you something
about traffic signal
control in general
because it's something
that isn't covered in a lot
of the standard transportation
planning curriculum.
So there are two basic
paradigms for signal control.
One is fully actuated and
the other is coordinated.
So fully actuated
that's uncoordinated.
With fully actuated that
means every approach
I've got detectors.
And the standard
detector it's a loop
of copper in the
street, a couple
rounds that goes to a box.
And through the miracles
of electromagnetism
if a vehicle drives over
it, it induces a voltage.
And you can pick
up that voltage,
and so you know
there's a car there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PETER FURTH: So
there is a setting
of how much of a voltage
change is enough because it
has to become digital.
It's either 0 or 1.
So if we increase
the sensitivity,
then it'll detect a bike.
But then the danger
is it will also detect
a car in the next lane over.
So there is a trade off there.
So then if we want
to detect bikes,
we use a figure 8 configuration.
And then we try to educate the
bicyclists, drive right down
the middle of that figure 8.
And that's where you'll
get picked up the most.
Hardly anybody
knows that though.
There's another solution
to bike detection, which
is if you're a bicyclist
like me, I like green.
I like red.
I like yellow.
I like all colors.
I just go.
All right.
So with fully actuated
control I've got detectors.
And based on those
detectors, I will
know how many seconds
has it been since a car
passed through and
[AUDIO OUT] gap.
And once the gap reaches
a certain threshold,
2 and 1/2 seconds, 3 seconds,
then you have gapped out.
Boom, your turn is over.
And it's the next one's turn.
So there's no
fixed cycle length.
Who knows?
If traffic volume is light, we
serve you, we serve the next,
we serve the next,
and now we're back.
Traffic is heavy.
It might take 90
seconds to cycle around.
But it's completely
flexible like that.
And if I interrupt something
like that for transit
priority and now
there's a longer queue--
OK, everybody's been waiting
an extra 15 seconds because
of this transit priority.
Well, when their turn comes
up if they've got more cars,
well the detector will say,
hey, they still have cars,
still have cars, yeah.
So keep them going,
keep them going.
OK.
Now we finally have a gap
you're over, onto the next one.
And if East Street
like I was saying
has less traffic, the street
that the bus was on because it
got that green extension,
when its turn comes up instead
of holding the
light for 35 seconds
like it usually does it'll
hold the light for 25 seconds
and then say, I'm all done.
No more traffic.
So fully actuated control is a
great background for priority
because it's inherently
flexible, it's cycle free,
it has that built
in compensation.
But then there's another
way of doing control,
another basic
paradigm for control,
which is coordinated control.
In the US, I'm
showing the most kind
of the basic paradigm, which
is the dual ring with eight
phases.
I'm not including right turns
because right turns usually
don't have their own lights.
The right turns just go
with the through movements.
And with coordinated
control like this
we have EBL, that means
eastbound left, westbound
through, WBT, westbound through.
So the east-west
street has its time.
There's an upper ring
and a lower ring.
And the rings that
are in parallel they
can move together.
So when the light starts
green, eastbound left
and westbound left, one and
five, they're green together.
What comes next, two or six?
That depends.
Whichever one has more
traffic, one or five,
that will stay green
because it has detectors
while the other one gaps out.
So maybe five gaps out first
because it had less traffic.
Then six becomes
green along with one.
Eventually one gaps out, and
now six is green along with two.
But then six and two
have to end together.
And then we have the same thing
for the north-south street.
So this could be fully
actuated, but when
I say it's coordinated
what I mean
is phases two and six those
are the coordinated phases.
And the cycle goes from
the end of two and six
until the next end
of two and six.
And that is a fixed
amount of time.
So if it's 110
second cycle, it's
always 110 seconds
from this point
until when it
comes around again.
These phases can
have some actuation.
They can have some detectors.
And so they might run
shorter than scheduled.
And if they gap out
quicker, run short,
and this one gaps out, it
runs short, this one gaps out,
it runs short that means two and
six are going to start early.
But if they start early,
they never end early.
They run their full
length because that's
how we have the full cycle.
And the advantage
to do that is when
you have many signals
in a line on an arterial
and you want a green
wave, you have them
all on the same cycle.
And then you have their
different offsets.
So let's say signal 1 it's
green starts at time 0.
The next one that's maybe 20
seconds away, well it's green
starts at time 20.
And that way the cars
can get a green wave.
That's the idea.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are these doing that
while left turns [INAUDIBLE]??
PETER FURTH: Yeah.
As I drew it here, it's
protected left turns.
You can have protected
plus permitted.
I mean there are variations.
If there might be no left turns,
then you can just take them out
but that's the basic scheme.
Now, what I want you to
think about is suppose
the bus is on phase two
which is a common case.
That's your Main Street the
street that's coordinated.
And the bus says, I
need an extension.
Extend the green.
All right.
We're going to borrow some
time from the later phases.
So we're going to hold the
light green an extra 15 seconds.
But remember we are
guaranteeing that at the end
we've got to be on time again.
So now we've only got 85 seconds
left to complete the cycle.
And phase two and
six, they are not only
guaranteed their
ending time, they're
also guaranteed
they're starting time.
So that means we have to take
those 15 seconds out of 3, 7,
4, 8, and 1, 5.
So to make things simple let's
only look at the bottom ring.
So I have to take 15 seconds.
The first generation, they
would take the whole 15
seconds out of phase
seven and then phase seven
would get canceled.
Well that caused big problems.
So now what they'll do
is they'll proportionally
take it out.
So let's say phase
seven is normally
scheduled to have 20 seconds,
and this one is normally
scheduled at 30 seconds,
scheduled to have 20 seconds.
So 20, 30, 20,
that's sums up to 70.
So I'm taking 15 seconds out.
So a portion of that I'd take
from you, I'd take from you,
I'd take from you.
You get the idea.
Is there any compensation
going on here?
None at all.
Phase six, the coordinated
phase, got an extra 15 seconds.
But the competing phases,
they all got cut short.
And now phase six comes
up for a full phase.
That's the way our coordinated
systems are programmed to work.
They don't have to be
programmed that way,
but that's the way they are.
If you buy them from
any American supplier,
that's how they're
programmed to work.
So when you say let's
add transit priority
on top of that, now
you can understand
why the traffic engineers
say, I don't know
about a 30 second extension.
Or oh, after giving
priority in one cycle
we better not give
priority in the next.
Because it can really
screw up traffic.
It lacks this mechanism
for compensation.
And compensating would be easy.
It would be say, let seven run
for its full scheduled time
unless it gaps out.
I mean if it gaps out if
there's no traffic, don't.
And allow six to
start late because six
got some extra time.
It probably doesn't
need its full amount.
But we don't do that.
And then if we do
a longer extension,
we get out of coordination,
we have to return back,
and I won't go into that.
I'll talk about a second
tactic, and then I'm
going to take a break so you
can hear about how they've done
priority in the Netherlands.
A second tactic is
Early Green, OK?
So in this diagram,
the phase that's green,
that's the phase in which
the bus is coming, OK?
And the phases that
precede it, those
are competing phases, the
cross street or left turns
that are waiting, OK?
And the red dash line,
that's when in the cycle
the bus is going to arrive.
So I've got a
situation where the bus
is expected to arrive near
the beginning of the left turn
phase.
And then it would have
to wait through the end
of the left turn phase.
And finally its
phase would be green.
So with early green, I could
shorten the left turn phase.
I could even shorten the
north-south phase before it.
So that now it's a shorter wait
until the bus's green comes up.
Maybe I even skip the left turn.
I shorten the through,
phase skip the left turn
and really make things
better for the bus that way.
So an interesting way
to look at early green
compared to green extension.
It's a small benefit because
if I make the green start
10 seconds early, that will
reduce the delay for the bus
by 10 seconds.
Remember with green
extension, 10 second extension
could save a bus 90 seconds.
But this-- it's a small
benefit, but who benefits?
Any bus arriving on red.
And red is usually a long time,
and a large percentage of buses
arrive on red.
Actually, the early part of
green, buses can also benefit.
So it's a small benefit to
a large number of buses.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For skip you
have the question marks.
Why wouldn't you just flip the
two cycles, flip the left--
PETER FURTH: Well
that's a great idea.
Flipping them,
but now then you'd
have to give that
tactic a different name.
And that name is
called phase rotation.
So yeah.
And some people think phase
rotation is an invitation
to traffic Armageddon.
It's going to be disaster.
Cars are going to be
smashing into each other
because people
expect their phase
to come up at a certain time.
And if it doesn't, they're going
to think the light is broken
and go through.
This is something
that can be tested.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was just going to
ask whether or not--
I think I've been at
a light before where
I had a skipped left turn
and I was pretty pissed off.
I was just curious
how that goes down.
How many people does it--
PETER FURTH: So in Zurich when
the traffic signal programmers
said, we can give better
priority if we can do this.
The higher ups were
worried about so they
said, what we're
going to do is we're
going to have a campaign
in which we're going to let
the people in the city know
that for the next six months
the sequence of
traffic signals is
going to be completely random.
Just wait until
your green comes up.
And they did that.
And then they went to
having a phase rotation.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it the
law that you're supposed
to wait until the green light?
And they're assuming people--
PETER FURTH: Yeah.
So in my life-- and my life is
a little longer than yours, so
in my lifetime of being
out on the streets
and I do drive a car sometimes,
once I went through a red light
because I waited
like two whole cycles
and my phase never came up.
So I figured the
detector was broken
and there's no traffic around
here anyway, so I'm going.
So people will do
that now and then.
It doesn't happen often though.
But what you say about
won't people wait,
there is one class of
people who won't wait.
And that's called bicyclists.
So you got to
watch out for them.
Think about their safety.
Now, in practice, often
you can't get much benefit
from early green
because who's green
are you trying to cut short?
If what you're
trying to cut short
is the cross streets green,
the cross streets green
is often determined
by pedestrians.
And we don't cut
pedestrian phases.
Pedestrians and transit you
know we're on the same team.
We don't want to hurt one to
help the other because all
of our transit passengers become
pedestrians as soon as they
get off the bus.
So a lot of times you just can't
do early green because you've
got a wide street, the cars
need about 15 seconds of green
to get through, but the
pedestrians need 24 seconds.
So the green light's
24 seconds, it's
entirely because it's
what the pedestrians need.
You can't cut that short.
So that's a practical issue
that early green there
are limitations unless you
can detect the bus really
far in advance and cut
something else short.
So let me take a break now
and introduce Jan Nederveen.
Jan is a senior transportation
planner with the city of Delft.
And I get the privilege every
summer for the last 10 years,
I've been taking 20 or
25 Northeastern students
to Delft for five weeks
for a course in sustainable
transportation.
And there they get to enjoy
incredible bike paths,
incredible roundabouts,
streets rebuilt
to be safe for
public transportation
systems, new train
station, fantastic stuff.
And it turns out the guy who
plans a lot of this stuff
is sitting right here.
And he often speaks
to our students
and explains it and the
philosophy behind it.
So Jan, would you come and
say something about how do you
do transit priority in Delft.
JAN NEDERVEEN: OK.
Welcome.
Thank you for having me here.
I'm going to tell you something
that works that I don't do
but my colleagues do.
I've got three people in
my department doing traffic
engineering, traffic lights.
They design it, they build
it, and they maintain it.
So what I'll show you here
is part of the thoughts
they have done and I only
focus on public transport.
Peter offers many times
a lot about cycling
but this time it will
be public transport.
First I'll give you some
views about the network.
And then I'll show you the
two current types of priority
we give.
We do physical priority,
and we do time priority.
I'll show you some slides
for some examples of Delft.
First our city Delft,
100,000 residents close to
of The Hague with
600,000 residents.
That's how we oriented
in the busiest part,
dense part of the Netherlands.
First we had one system
to try to serve everybody.
And we didn't succeed in it
because our public transport
system was too slow.
And then we figured
out, oh, that's good.
We have two kinds of groups
we like to facilitate.
One group are the commuters
going to their work.
And what they love is
speed as soon as possible
going to destination.
In their view they only need one
stop between their front door
and at their destination.
And everything between
is not needed for them.
Well, I need to collect
so much more passengers
that we say, we
make straight lines,
few stops, serving high
dense volume housing
with high dense jobs together.
And then you can go for the
high speed, the high quality,
and we see that we
attract more passengers.
The second group is everybody
else-- usually elderly people,
people without a job.
And we focus on them, as
you say, they need coverage.
They have to go to
many local locations.
So we make a citywide
network covering every area.
And that is located
on a lower speed
because I have to cover
everything low frequency.
That's the way we
handle public transport.
The first group is
growing, the second group
is stable If you
look at the data.
This is how our network works.
I've got a purple line.
That's the Delft railway system
connecting all major cities
of the Netherlands.
If you get in Delft
central station,
within an hour you're
standing on the central market
in Amsterdam, within 10
minutes to 50 minutes
you're in Rotterdam
or The Hague.
Nationwide system very good
quality, 11 trains each hour
each direction.
So it's perfect.
If you live in Delft, you
can reach 1 million jobs
within 45 minutes.
So if you need a
place, live in Delft.
That's our first system.
The second one, if I asked
the people what do they like,
most people like
light rail like tram.
There's a large group of car
drivers who love light rail
and don't like buses.
So I tried to convert my
complete network to light rail.
That is the dotted
lines over here.
The red ones are already
built. And we're still
talking with the
regional government
to get funding
for the black one.
And if that's done,
you see a spider kind
of network covering
most of the city.
And I add some regional bus
lines through its radial lines.
That's the next
coverage of our system.
And that's the commuter network.
And that's the last network
covering everything.
Step on a bus, pay $2,
you've got the whole city
to view if you've got the time.
That's how we cover
the complete area.
And the last group is
transport on demand.
If you're unable to use a public
bus, we use smaller buses.
You have to phone
every one hour, search
a bus driving through, and you
were picked up and delivered
door to door transport.
It's a fantastic system
but it's awful expensive.
So what we're trying to do is
get people out of this system,
this market is growing,
and getting them back
in a normal bus.
So we modify the bus so they
are more attractive for people
with light handicaps.
And the other thing we
are thinking about, maybe
we can offer a discount to the
buses as a sort of timetable.
We have a line structure for
driving that kind of business.
So it looks like more
public transport which
makes it more cheaper to run.
Physical priority.
That's the first thing we do.
If a bus is in the same lane
as a car or if there's many
bicycles usually
there's the same speed,
and I cannot give
them any priority,
let's give them bus lines.
Where the center of city,
center is city Delft, that
is the downtown area, the
central market square,
this is where all the shops
are and all the restaurants.
That's the most
historical center.
It's a lovely place to be.
You see the square over there,
that is the central railroad
station.
If you'd like to leave
the city, go there.
And we designed
all the bus lines
going to the central
railroad station.
We can give them good
priority on that location.
When do we need a bus lane?
We need it if there is a delay
of driving with the cars.
So on busy streets I
like to have a bus lane.
And that's difficult because
if it's a busy street,
you need probably four lanes
or two lanes of car traffic.
And I'm asking one lane
for six or eight buses
per hour in each direction.
So then we have to compete, as
I said, in the busiest areas.
We start searching for a bus
lane or a light rail lane
so we can give them priority.
And elsewhere-- this
is a residential area,
it's nice to have but you
don't need to have it.
This was thought in
the 80s, OK, let's
make a bus lane everywhere
so we get the bus
lane in a residential area.
And the only place
we need it that it's
crossing the highway
in that location
is because that's our
big intersections.
Another part of priority is at
the central station of Delft.
This area, if you
look at Delft and you
take in Delft area,
urban development,
railroad you see a huge
development in the downtown
area.
Over here is the old station.
Over there is a new one.
We have spent 500 million Euros
to get the railroad tracks
under the ground
for 1 and 1/2 miles.
And we built a complete railroad
station, a new bus platform,
and we did a complete separation
of all the transfer flows.
On the surface level we
offered public transport.
So in the open air,
that's public transport.
On minus one, in
the basement, we
have the huge parking
facility with parking lanes
underground to bus platform.
So we have a physical
separation of the bike transport
going to the railroad station
and the bus transport.
Now on level minus two, we
have the railroad tracks.
That's one way of separation.
You can see it here
in the picture.
This is the town hall,
the glass building.
And the first floor,
the ground floor,
that's the railroad station.
We have the name Delft on it.
And underneath in
it right, you can
see people standing at the
entrance of the parking garage.
We've got 100,000
people living in Delft.
This parking garage for
bicycles is today 8,000 places,
and it's not enough.
So a few years later there
will be 10,000 places
for 100,000 residents.
So bike parking
is very important.
AUDIENCE: There's also
the university there,
so they're not all residents.
Yeah.
Not all the students are
residents [INAUDIBLE]..
JAN NEDERVEEN: Yeah.
It's students.
It's also residents now.
Yes.
OK.
But when the students
are at the university
and you look at the parking
facility, it's also full.
And other people leaving Delft.
Some of them are
also students going
into a university in
Leiden or in Rotterdam
but also normal people like
myself are parking there.
It's not a student
parking garage.
Yeah.
It's true that a large
group of them are students.
Well minus one is for the
bikes and the bus platform
is operational on this level.
So buses don't have to deal
with cars or with pedestrians
or with bikes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So if minus
one is parking for bikes,
do they also travel on that
level or do they [INAUDIBLE]??
JAN NEDERVEEN: The bikes
also travel on minus one.
The bike lane goes
here under this bridge
and then entering the park.
You can see there's
a rim over it.
So he has a complete
separation to minus one
in the most busiest area.
And that saves me a lot of
time because the first traffic
light, very close to
the railroad station,
should otherwise have to deal
with 10,000 bicycles a day.
But I've offered
them a tunnel so I've
got a normal intersection
with a normal traffic light.
All the rest I cannot handle
that amount of cyclists,
and this Peter here among
this group, he will not stop.
Here's an aerial
view of the system.
The town hall is in the front.
And we have also an
east-west separation.
On the down inner city
side that's over here,
we put the bus lane,
the light rail lane.
And on the other side, we've got
the lane with the car traffic.
And that's very important
because at the top
of the picture on
the left side, I
have an intersection where all
public transport has to make
all the left or right turns.
And that's the
only one that make
that turn because the
car route is blocked
and the bike lane is
underground in a tunnel.
So I have an intersection
where only public transport
makes left and right turns.
And on the other intersection
that's almost falling off
the picture on the
right side, that
is my car intersection where
all the light rail traffic only
has to cross, they
go straight through.
So it was much easier to handle
if a separate public transport
and car transport on
different intersections.
And my transport engineers were
interested in traffic lights.
I took them, let me have a
look if this is the same.
Can you build a traffic
light for this location?
Because the alternative was one
big crossing with everything,
and that didn't work.
I do also have some discussions
with my urban planners.
And they love the light rail and
the green grass in the middle.
And my public
transport here, lots
of asphalt. What do you like?
I pick you out.
Which one would
you like and why?
AUDIENCE: I'd prefer the
light lines because I feel
like you're more in tune with--
you experience the
road better that way.
You can serve the
demand like that.
You should go green.
JAN NEDERVEEN: So
which one do you
like, the light rail in
the green or the light rail
in the asphalt?
AUDIENCE: In the green.
JAN NEDERVEEN: In the green.
It's lovely, nicer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAN NEDERVEEN: Yeah.
Well we had that
discussion also.
I also think the top picture
is the most beautiful.
But this has one
big disadvantage.
If I have a bus link or
a public transport link
but I like to operate buses
as well as light rail,
in this situation they can
both use the same line.
And I've got one
platform, and you
can decide if you take
a bus or light rail.
And the one on top, if I would
like to add the bus lane,
well that would be a bus
stop without priority
on the normal street.
I [INAUDIBLE] that
one because it
doesn't have a bus lane
anymore because I replaced it
by a light rail.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What is the typical
frequency of light rail lines?
JAN NEDERVEEN: The minimum
is four light rail vehicles
an hour each direction.
That's the minimum.
Otherwise--
AUDIENCE: Rush hour?
JAN NEDERVEEN: It goes
up to 6 or 8 in Delft.
And in other cities
it can be more.
But eight is all pretty much
for city with 100,000 people.
And it has to
compete with cycling.
So many people who
cycle you take them out
from the public
transport system.
These guys, cab
drivers always ask me,
may I use your bus lanes?
Because they are so fast and
they have beautiful traffic
lights.
I couldn't find a letter
size bigger than this one.
I said no!
Absolutely not!
I've got maybe 2018 cabs
in Delft, but it's no, no.
AUDIENCE: It's not more
efficient than driving.
JAN NEDERVEEN: Oh, they
love to drive my bus
lanes like the fire
department, who is pretty fast,
but no way I want it.
Because if they enter
a huge intersection
and there is a bus going
at that intersection,
I know that bus will
make a left turn.
Because every bus on that
intersection will make a left
turn.
And that means all other
directions can get green.
I don't know where
that cab is going.
So you have to completely block
the intersection for one cab.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is that London
lets taxis use the bus lanes?
Are you familiar with that?
JAN NEDERVEEN: In London?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAN NEDERVEEN: Yeah,
maybe they block out
all the other directions
to give them the priority.
And that will seriously harm
all other modes of transport.
It would harm car
traffic and bike traffic.
And we like to give priority
to the buses with many people,
but this is one
taxi who have maybe
one or two people inside it.
That's not worth the effort.
And it's a big risk
to give him green
and see what is happening.
Time priority.
Peter already taught some
things but that is what we do.
You have special traffic
lights, the [INAUDIBLE] traffic
lights that's in the picture on
the black/white border column.
That's showing if you get green
to left or to right or straight
through for our bus.
And we have two
kinds of detection.
The first one is
the intelligent one.
So every vehicle says,
I'm bus 24 vehicle number,
so I should be here
20 minutes past five.
So it's also telling
it's time per table.
And then we know, OK,
you're one minute early,
we will not give you priority
That's the expensive one.
And the other one, that's
a simple detection.
Some vehicle is crossing
a detector and notice, oh,
this is a vehicle.
I even don't know
which bus it is.
Even if you are a
car you are detected
and then you get some priority.
That's the way of detection.
The top one is the best.
So if we are in charge and
it's our traffic light,
we put in the intelligent one.
If somebody is else
doing the design,
a regional government,
sometimes you get the cheap one.
Especially in the Delft
University, top technology
campus, the cheap
one is installed.
Traffic light priority.
Peter showed you a bus stop
close to an intersection.
Well, here's an example of
a traffic light priority
at a huge intersection.
The term has to make
a turn to the left.
And what we do, we
put in to two lines.
The first one is
the location where
the light rail, the [AUDIO OUT]
for handling the passengers.
I don't know how
long that will take.
And I don't want to stop all
the other traffic because he
is still handling passengers.
If I do so, I get many
letters from people
waiting for nothing.
So there's a second
stop line, go
straightforward on
the intersection.
And then the light
rail will [INAUDIBLE],,
hey, hello I'm here.
Please can you give
me what priority.
And what this system does,
he will not break off
all the other signals.
He says, oh, I've
finished my phase,
I then add in the phase
with public transport,
and then I continue
with all the rest.
I don't take out any
time from the others,
just merge in a priority
for the traffic lights.
So this intersection
is four phases
so there are four chances
to give him priority.
So the waiting time is
not a full cycle but only
a quarter of it.
That's how it works.
This is that same
intersection from the air.
So it's a huge one, the
biggest intersection
we have in the built up area.
We have total detection
all directions.
Also the bicycles are detected.
We have a detector.
We don't use an eight.
We've got a good detector.
So we detect bikes.
There also is a button if you
like, but most of the time
you're already detected.
We have a fixed sequence
which groups go together.
And what the sequence is?
We have defined a
maximum green time
that might be possible
for each direction.
And we stop giving green if we
achieve a free flow situation.
So I don't give green
to free flow traffic.
And if the traffic's
still congested
after a certain amount of time
we say, OK, now it's enough,
now the others have to go.
You have bus priority and light
rail priority and fire truck
priority.
And we don't build
intersections in Delft.
We have a traffic light
sequence of 120 seconds.
That's the max.
So if the area is congested,
the maximum cycle time
is 1 minute and 20 seconds.
And my [INAUDIBLE] if you
look at our intersections,
I'm trying to bring
back the cycle
time for as many intersections
back to 90 seconds.
And they did and for most
intersections it worked.
And it was a huge
benefit for everybody.
The maximum waiting time
is reduced 30 seconds.
So if you missed going
first 30 seconds,
you're simply reducing
the cycle time.
You can also do it
physically, make
your intersections smaller.
That's a huge benefit
for the cycling time.
And we noticed
some intersections
were pretty sharp, 90 seconds.
People get used to
it so they didn't
miss the first second of green.
They were green,
[INAUDIBLE],, driving.
So we could handle the
same number of cars
in a shorter green time.
A special one was the
fire truck priority.
The fire department has a depot
exactly at that intersection.
And they've got a
beautiful red button.
So if I press that red
button, the intersection
will stand in a way that
the order directions
are blocked that the fire
department has to cross.
So if you're not in
the direction of a fire
that the fire
department has to go,
you still get green because it
is an intelligence red button.
So I press this button showing
I have a fire in Delft North,
and they will follow this route.
Then that route will get
green for the fire truck
on the time we think
he will be there.
So while driving North,
he continues detected,
and the traffic lights
are switched that way
that we will get green.
We do not block completely
all these intersections
for the fire trucks since
he knows if we do so,
we might cause a traffic jam
because all the directions
are blocked.
And that's the way
how we get there.
And we also detect if you
pressed the right button
and if we make a system that is
going perfectly to the north.
Maybe he didn't use that
route but in certain times
the system arguments,
OK, I did the measuring
so somebody has disappeared
or gone somewhere else.
Well let's switch
back to normal.
That's the fire priority
we've got in Delft.
And it was very important when
we built the railroad tunnel
because the whole area
was under construction
with all the traffic lights
kept to that priority.
And that's the
example from Delft.
Thank you.
PETER FURTH: My new graphic.
Yeah.
So I told you that [AUDIO OUT]
are green extension, which
is great if you've
got a far side stop
and you can predict events.
Early green, which is
a little more limited
but we need more flexibility.
So like what Jan was
describing there,
they have these four
phases in the cycle.
To make it simple,
let's just say
we have east and west left
and then east and west through
and then north and south
left and north and south
through, phase one, two,
three, four, and the tram,
in this case,
because it actually
conflicts with all of them.
So the normal thinking of a
traffic engineer would be,
OK, and then we'll
have a tram phase here.
And now that's the cycle.
But the Delft thinking is,
we'll put a tram phase here,
and a tram phase here.
And if there's no
tram, well we skip it.
And if there is a tram,
then the tram gets to go.
So the tram never
has to wait long.
So that's part of the, if we
can get a man on the moon,
we can turn the light green.
So let me say something.
I'll leave the rest
of these plans.
They have some details there.
But let me tell you something
about D Street and the Silver
Line, OK?
So the Waterfront Silver Line--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PETER FURTH: Huh?
AUDIENCE: Do you have a video?
PETER FURTH: No, no.
I'm not going to do the video.
This is something new.
How many of you are familiar
with the Silver Line that
goes to and from the airport?
Yeah.
D street is where, if you're
going toward the airport,
it comes out of the tunnel and
then it stops at a red light.
And while you're waiting at
the red light you can watch,
and there's no cars going by.
And you think, why
is the light red?
So on a map here's
Congress Street.
This is D Street.
And then this is
Silver Line Way.
So the traffic
engineers are concerned
that that's a short distance.
And if they turn the light
red for Congress Street,
two bad things can happen.
One is spill back.
Traffic comes to here,
oh, the light is red,
and now queue spills back,
and it hurts the capacity.
And the second
one is starvation.
The light turns green here
for northbound traffic,
but the light is still red here.
So cars start to go, but nobody
can go because they're stuck.
It's starved.
So they don't want to
close D Street while either
of those things can happen.
So there is a cycle;
it's a 120 second cycle.
This time I'll draw
the cycle in a circle.
And they've decided
here is the time
in the cycle the bus can go.
So that's why you just
wait, you just wait.
You arrive and you just wait
until your time in the cycle.
So I just recently
had some students
study it in my advanced
traffic control class.
We actually took the whole
class there for a field trip
during morning peak hour
because I had to see it myself.
Is it really the disaster
people talk about?
It is not a traffic disaster.
It is a transit disaster because
the frequency the Silver Line,
it's about one bus
every two minutes,
and they go in both directions.
So that means in a
120 second cycle,
if they're perfectly
on schedule,
you'd have one bus at
most one per direction.
Of course they're not.
So often you've got
two buses, sometimes
three buses waiting to go.
And they wait, and they
wait, and they wait,
and they wait, and
most of the time
there is no conflicting traffic.
So my students learn how
to do traffic simulations.
There's some standard
packages for that.
They learn how to program
their own traffic control.
And they said, let's try just
all out aggressive priority.
When we detect the bus,
we just stop the street,
let the bus go through.
The bus only needs like 14
seconds, and then it goes back.
And I can hear
people saying, oh,
but sometimes you've got to
serve two or three buses.
Yeah, when buses have to wait
two minutes till their turn
comes.
But when they
don't have to wait,
you're never going to be
serving more than one at a time.
And it only takes 15 seconds.
We put that into the
simulation to see, OK,
how's it going to affect cars?
How is it going to affect buses?
Average delay for bus
goes from 50 seconds down
to four seconds.
Why four?
That's only because if we do
turn the light green for a bus,
for the cars a minimum 20
second before the next bus.
So there's a bus
in one direction,
the bus coming in
the other direction
15 seconds later might
have to wait a few seconds.
So delay for bus goes
down almost zero.
Delay for cars also goes
down because the system
they have now will stop the
cars even when there's no bus.
I don't know why.
And there's another thing
about the system they have now
that is not so intelligent.
So the main message
I want to get across
is the old way I said is if
we can put a man on the moon,
we can get the light to
turn green for the bus.
That is if you use
intelligent tactics,
we can almost always
reduce the delay
for a bus down to near
zero without really
increasing the delay for cars.
Bus only needs a few
seconds to get through.
They just need a few
seconds at the right time.
Just rearrange the
time a little bit.
Give the bus the
green when it needs.
And what's in the way is
this inflexible paradigm
of fixed time control with a
fixed cycle, long fixed cycles.
Like Jan was saying, the
long cycles are killer.
If you have short cycles,
the delay won't be too much.
So what Europe has done
with transit priority
is just amazing.
Some of the things
that I saw there, it
just blew my mind
how they're just
giving priority to transit.
They just do it.
There was an intersection
in The Hague,
right near Delft, where a
tram line was intersecting
the main ring road.
Lots of traffic and
big traffic jams.
And my friends are telling me,
oh yeah, big traffic jams here.
How come?
Well because we have to
give the tram priority.
It's like you just have to.
You drink coffee in the morning,
and you give the tram priority.
Who would ever think of making
the tram wait at a red light?
No!
You have to give
the tram priority.
And there are lots of trams.
And it's causing
a big traffic jam.
So what's the solution?
Spend a lot of money, grade
separation, and now the tram
has absolutely zero delay.
And the cars go underneath,
and they have no delay either,
and everybody's happy.
But it started because
of this attitude
that we just give priority to
our important transit lines.
So if we have that
attitude, we can
do it a lot better
than what we're doing.